over the past several months there has
been an influx of so-called
moon boys within reddit stock twits the
youtube comments
and basically every other medium of
online communication
for the first time in history bad news
is
good news in fact the worse the news the
better
is a company accused of fraud it's time
to buy
is a company massively shorted and in a
dying industry
it's time to buy is a company or a
crypto a popular meme
well you know the deal it's time to buy
a dip and take this trash
to the moon the worst part is that
recent market conditions have rewarded
such behavior
prompting these individuals to
continuously gamble their gains
on quote-unquote the next short squeeze
or the next dogecoin
and honestly if they don't take profits
and stop while they can
their portfolio is going to end up being
the next big connect
so here's the appallingly toxic culture
of moon boys
before we get started i wanted to make
it clear that i agree that hedge funds
and market makers are evil
they manipulate markets they manipulate
news they manipulate emotions
really there's nothing that they don't
manipulate but
yellowing one's entire money on a
nameless penny stock or altcoin is not
the solution
in fact you're probably increasing the
likelihood of handing over
everything to the big boys and here's
why
first of all moon boys are
cherry-picking favorable results
people who got in early and took profits
were able to profit hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars
but gamestop was a 1 in 10 million or a
1 in 100 million outcome
you could argue that tesla's run-up was
also a massive short squeeze
but there were many factors hyping up
tesla's run more than a simple technical
short squeeze
really the last time a spectacular short
squeeze happened was with volkswagen way
back in 2008
and no retail investors were really
involved in that short squeeze
but you don't even have to look that far
to understand the low probability
of another short squeeze gamestop is one
of the most popular events of 2021
even people who have never invested in
their entire life have heard about the
gamestop story
considering this don't you think hedge
funds and market makers who work on wall
street all day
every day know about it as well wouldn't
it make sense that they would be far
more careful now that they took a
massive loss
i mean it sounds like common sense yet
we see new short squeeze opportunities
posted on reddit and stock twits on a
daily basis whether that be microvision
nicola blink or amc basically any stock
that's down 70 or 80 percent
and has a massive short interest is a
new short squeeze target
i mean if you want to throw one or two
percent of your portfolio into one of
these companies just for the fun of it
go right ahead but moon boys are often
taking out lines of credit on their
homes
maxing out their credit cards and
throwing everything they have on some
pipe dream short squeeze
the worst part is that they often
convince new and naive investors have no
idea what's happening to do the exact
same thing
is it going to work for someone yes but
someone is also always going to win the
lottery
anyways moving away from short squeeze
moon boys we have altcoin moonboys
here it's basically the exact same thing
but even worse
instead of pointing to gamestop altcoin
moon boys point to dogecoin
they claim that worthless all coins like
safe moon coin and
shiba coin and these nutscoin are going
to the moon
and yes there's actually an altcoin
called these nutscoin
the reason all coin moonboys are even
worse is that the only people they're
screwing over
are their peers with short squeezes the
people who are hurt the most are also
usually just retailers who got in late
but there's at least a chance that hedge
funds and market makers could get hurt
with these nameless altcoins though the
only person getting hurt
is retailers as no institution is going
to touch these worthless pieces of
garbage
with all the coins scummy individuals
are literally running pump and dumps
in broad daylight are there naive moon
boys involved in these schemes that
don't know exactly what they're doing
probably but the people at the top of
these pyramids know exactly what they're
doing
all they're doing is hyping up coins to
inflate the price so that they can dump
at the top i mean this is literally what
the wolf of wall street did with penny
stocks
and it landed him in two years in
federal prison the altcoin ponzi leaders
are straight up committing fraud
and theft in broad daylight but since
cryptocurrencies aren't regulated they
can get away with it
it's really quite disgusting aside from
selling pipe dreams and new investors
moon boys are constantly normalizing
ludicrous losses on reddit
and stock twits we're talking about 70
even 90 losses and it's not like they're
putting in a hundred dollars and lost 80
bucks
no these guys put in hundreds of
thousands of dollars and they often lose
hundreds of thousands take a look at
this wall street bets poster
he lost and twelve thousand dollars this
guy lost ninety five thousand dollars
and this guy lost five hundred and
eighty nine thousand dollars
on wall street bets and stock twits
these aren't warnings to stay away
or stories of people learning their
lessons no these are proud battle scars
most of these gamblers think that
they're a brave soldier holding the line
and that they're going to be rewarded
massively when the short squeeze finally
begins
in the future they think that this loss
will be a funny story and that they can
laugh about
it maybe in a year they can post a new
story that's like
oh yeah i was done half a meal last year
but now
i'm up 10 mil in reality though the only
thing that's going to be funny at the
end of the day
is their final account value after they
blew 100 because of pure stupidity
now i feel bad for people who randomly
get screwed out of nowhere
but these guys man they're just asking
for it
they take pride in holding massive bags
and having what they call
diamond hands diamond hands are awesome
if you invested into a fundamentally
strong company that's vastly undervalued
but these guys are buying into pure hype
and are hoping that things get even more
heated
sometimes this strategy even works but
instead of taking profits along the way
they end up losing most of their gains
this poster for instance started from 10
000 and skyrocketed all the way up to
1.6 million dollars
he could have taken profits right then
and there but he ended up writing it
down to 250 000
granted he did sell 25x's money but
that's still such a sad story
imagine if he just sold 10 of his
position for every 100 000
he made or what if he just put a stop
loss at 1 million dollars
if you're so confident in your thesis
putting in a stop loss wouldn't matter
right
the stop loss should theoretically never
hit but on the off chance it did hit
you would guarantee yourself one million
dollars free tax
unfortunately though that would be
classified as having paper hands
and that's a big no-no amongst these
communities risk management and smart
trading tactics
are for losers here it's either ride or
die with diamond hands
not only do these communities encourage
people to not sell until some fairy tale
number is reached
but they also promote infinitely buying
the dip again
buying the dip is a great strategy when
you're investing into fundamentally
sound companies like amazon or
apple but moon boys aren't buying dips
they're buying crashes
and falling knives there's always some
random hype that gets circulated amongst
these communities that's gonna be game
changing for the asset
you might hear that the big bad
institutions are trying to buy your
shares
at cheap prices or that they're trying
to shake out the weak hands and that the
pump is just around the corner
check out this gambler for instance his
thesis is that the iv
or implied volatility of gamestop
options is under 100
the company also has earnings and a
shareholder meeting coming soon
so this user decided to go ahead and buy
nearly 100 000
worth of 950 call options on gamestop
for those of you who aren't familiar
with call options this position
basically means that this user is
betting 100 000
the gamestop will be above 950 per share
by january of 2023. at least he bought
something with one and a half years to
play out
but man talk about risk management now
none of this is anything new people have
been using the stock market as a casino
for decades at this point
but with the success of gamestop and
deutsche coin more regular people are
falling into this trap than
ever before these people simply don't
understand the risks of investing into
short sweet stocks and hype cryptos
many of them think that dogecoin can be
worth tens of thousands of dollars just
like bitcoin one day
they're being sold a fantasy from moon
boys who either don't understand the
risks themselves
or their brain dead gamblers and
unfortunately the vast majority of these
individuals will end up losing
everything
anyone who tries to argue against these
moon boys or anyone who even tries to
simply outline the risks of such
activities
are labeled as gay bears there's going
to be comments down below
that i'm paid by hedge funds to spread
fear uncertainty and doubt
and i'm a tool for big money but in
reality
the real tool for big money is moon boys
and that brings me into my last point
which is that there is no larger mission
often times wall street bettors and moon
boys think that they're doing something
super noble
by taking down big money and helping the
little guy win even with gamestop
though the little guy didn't win sure
some retailers won but retail investors
as a whole did not win by
any means moon boys were super excited
that the hedge fund melvin capital lost
53 percent of their portfolio in january
but what people don't mention is that
melbourne capital gained 20
the very next month and at that rate
they'll probably be green
by the end of the year now you might be
saying that robin hood and the other
brook just came to their rescue
and that they would have gone under if
it wasn't for interference
but even if melvin capital and citron
research went bankrupt
who cares that's just a handful of hedge
funds
the hedge fund community would have
still won the gamestop fiasco
even if gamestop went to the moon and
hit two thousand or three thousand
dollars per share
here's the thing hedge funds don't just
short stocks
they also buy stocks just like retailers
in fact
the four largest asset managers in the
world own a total of 39 percent
of gamestop aside from these hedge funds
who already owned gamestop
dozens of hedge funds got in and got out
of gamestop
just like you and they made a lot
lot more even dfv who is likely the
retailer that benefited the most
only made 30 or maybe 40 million at the
peak which is of course
insane but a hedge fund named sandvest
management that decided to jump into the
gamestop frenzy
ended up pocketing 700 million dollars
if robin hood did not shut down gamestop
stock buying
not only would retailers have made
millions more but hedge funds on the
right side of the trade would have made
billions more so it's really not as
noble of a fight
as you might think at the end of the day
the stock and crypto markets have
skyrocketed over the past year
the p e ratio of the s p 500 would
suggest that we're actually a dock on
bubble levels
right now this massive speculation
across the stock market
has allowed a group of moon boys on
reddit stock twits and youtube
to make unprecedented returns within a
very short period of time
this short-term victory has led them to
believe that they can replicate these
results
over and over again adding a zero to
their portfolio with each subsequent win
but sooner or later the house of cards
will crumble
and most of them will lose everything
just like every other euphoric event
in history so be sure that you're not
the one that's diamond handing
the zero what do you guys think about
moonboys comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys think this
market is in need of some reason
and logic and of course consider joining
our discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one